well i think
you you you attend to it by saying that
our concept of nationhood
has got to be multi-faith
in other words the concept of a
of a state that is simply for one faith
um means that in the end you are
excluding people of a
of a different faith and you have to
argue that that such a
that's that a nation that is that is
exclusively the preserve of one faith
is runs contrary to the principles of
reconciliation
um now they may disagree with that okay
of course
but i think that's the argument you've
got to use so for example in the context
the middle east
where many israelis would talk about a
state for the jewish people
this is in my view has
meaning if it if it's in the same way
that you would say that
let's say indonesia is a predominantly
muslim country will be a muslim you
might describe it as a muslim country
right but if what it was was a statement
that you had to be jewish in order to
live in israel obviously that would be
wrong
right and so in a negotiation
one of the things you've got to do
sometimes in in political negotiation
is put down um
the red lines you know in other words
there's a point at which it's not worth
having the negotiation if the
negotiation
is to end up with something that is
contrary
to to to basic principles and here again
it's important that religious people are
there arguing
that even though we may be predominantly
of one religion within this state we
cannot and it is wrong and contrary to
our religion to exclude those of a
different religion from living here
and i think you know i reached this
point in the northern ireland
negotiation
on occasions when i would say if that's
the price of this
of the deal it's too high a price to pay
um partly because it's wrong and partly
because of course it's always
unsustainable
now you have actually a similar
situation which is in kosovo today
where
you know i found myself in quite an
unusual situation when i went back there
just a few months back
and you know because at one level people
there will
know me as someone who helped as it were
liberate
kosovo um
and they were rather surprised when i
went back there and said the first thing
i want to raise with you is the position
of
some of the serb christians who feel now
excluded and driven out
because that's not i i didn't do it for
that reason i didn't do it
because you were muslim right or
because you i did it because i thought
was wrong that ethnic cleansing should
happen and i
would think it if it was christians
ethnic cleansing muslims or muslims
ethnic cleansing christians
but if your concept of the state
does not allow for religious difference
then it's a concept that i wouldn't
personally want to support
so you know we got into quite an
interesting debate about that but it's a
very important
set you know at some point you've got to
lay down these red lines on this
otherwise
you actually end up you see then you end
up
actually sanctioning religious as a
badge
of identity religion as a badge of
identity in opposition to someone
rather than um an empowering set of
values that guide
people but where people can find
different paths to salvation